[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des centaines de poids lourds planté au
coeur d'ottawa la capitale canadienne
des chauffeurs routiers en colère
rejoint par des milliers de manifestants
car le seul pays de la zone euro le
grand pays qui a retrouvé aussi
rapidement son niveau d'activité d'avant
crise et qui a fait un rebond aussi
spectaculaire c'est la france donc
soyons fiers de ce que fait la france au
canada depuis le 30 novembre impossible
de se déplacer dans les transports
publics ou de sortir du pays sans
vaccination en janvier les indemnités
chômage ont été retirés au non vaccinés
évidemment que c'est un enjeu la
question de la bientraitance en
établissement en ehpad à ce point là là
évidemment que les révélations dans ce
livre j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire à
sourdeval tente pour certains
manifestants le canada est désormais une
dictature sanitaires il n'hésite pas à
exhiber des croix gammées et étoile
jaune les faits sont gravissimes pour
autant cette affaire ne doit pas être
l'arbre qui cache la forêt il existe un
autre pays une maltraitance structurelle
de nos aînés et c'est pour ça que
s'agissant du groupe orpea nous allons
lancer nous lançons deux enquêtes une
enquête administrative de l'inspection
générale des affaires sociales sur le
fonctionnement du groupe donc c'est une
première parce que il faut taper fort
plusieurs accusations sont infondées
j'en ai la preuve vous aurez tous les
éléments mais dans la tente de c2c de
ces éléments en toute transparence ne
nous
ne nous accusez pas vous savez que le dg
là qui vient d'être limogé il a vendu
ses actions parce qu'il savait que ça
allait sortir et va se gagner dus du blé
là dessus mais en plus de ça il touchait
un plus d'un million d'euros de salaire
par an évidemment que je ne vais pas
abandonner comme ça les gens âgés qui
vieillissent qui s'affaiblissent et ses
enjeux ce serait ça serait inhumain donc
ce que je dis contrôle évidemment
suppression des ars qui ont montré une
fois de plus qu'elle ne servait à rien
je sais qui se prend pour jupiter bien
sûr on a tous compris mais là faudrait
que jupiter descendre un peu sur terre
au moins le temps de la campagne
présidentielle il est candidat mais il a
un passif et il faut qu'il rende des
comptes au peuple français si c'est que
ces leaders politiques ne comprennent
pas qu'il ya une aspiration des
électeurs de gauche à l'union c'est
qu'ils sont pas à la hauteur de leurs
responsabilités latin mais bien sûr
qu'ils se réunissent qu'il se voit
qu'ils se réunissent qu'il discute je
pourrais dire qu ils tirent au sort
enfin qu'il discute
ceux qui aujourd'hui disent voter pour
moi ne voteront pas pour jean luc
mélenchon jeu je voulais que ça ne
s'additionnent pas parce que j'ai réussi
à mettre ses pensionnés aux deux
précédents ce que non ouais mais là mais
parce que c'est pas le même jean luc
mélenchon se présente là bas je vous lis
sur les sujets que j'ai mis en avant
notamment sur le nucléaire
vous défendez le revenu d'incitation
ouvrir à l'eau alors que moi je ne veux
pas je veux un revenu il est pareil
c'est une grande différence et ouvrir ce
sont me semble-t-il
des différences qui peuvent s'estomper
très facilement et qui ne sont rien par
jean luc mélenchon ce sera
l'ère des docks appelle madame le oui ça
m'amuse
je pense que de l'affection maintenant
l'arrivée ce que c'est que ces personnes
ce que j'appelle affectueusement les
punks à chiens